j
quand je suis devenu papa je me suis
demandé quel papa j'allais être plein de
questions sont venues et à chacune de
ces questions des myriades d'injonction
se sont proposés comme réponse des
injonctions parfois contradictoires
entre elles et parfois rigoureusement
inapplicable
ce qu'il fallait
qu'un enfant fini son assiette
est-ce qu'il fallait qu'un enfant ne
peut pas forcer à manger s'il n'avait
pas faim est-ce qu'il fallait coucher
ses enfants à 9 heures ou est-ce que
cela n'avait pas de sens
d'imposer un enfant de dormir s'il
n'avait pas sommeil
ce qu'il fallait qu'un enfant obéissent
à son père ou est-ce qu'il était normal
qu'un enfant en chine à faire quelque
chose qu'on lui demande s'il n'en
comprend pas le sens
comment choisir entre toutes ces
inventions
comment éviter d'être un papa arbitraire
et plus généralement comment échapper à
l'arbitraire puisque toutes nos
relations sociales de relations
amoureuses nos relations familiales de
relations professionnelles
nos relations avec nous mêmes sont
structurées par ses seins fonctions
la plupart du temps ces injonctions sont
des vestiges
des vestiges d'époque ou l'éducation
était envisagée comme un dressage
les style d'époque où il y avait des
dominants et des dominés et où des
relation de subordination était
pratiquement universelle
à cette époque on ne faisait pas
confiance aux enfants on ne faisait pas
confiance au phare on ne faisait pas
confiance à ceux qui travaillaient pour
nous
et bien entendu on les traitait en
conséquence on cherchait pas à les
accompagner à les soutenir
à les entendre on cherchait à les
maîtriser
à les encadrer
ah les asservir
la manière d'envisager les relations a
beaucoup changé mais les règles de la
famille et règles du couple
les règles de l'état de guerre évolué
comment expliquer dès lé permanence
comment expliquer une telle résistance
au changement de ces injonctions
en creusant j'ai vu que ces injonctions
été rarement visibles bien sûr il y en a
des injonctions visible c'est notamment
le cas des règles
byte impôts c'est l'heure d'aller à
l'école il faut arriver au bureau à 9h
on peut passer chez le dîner de noël
ces instructions sont parfois mal vécu
mais elle peut être
elles peuvent être facilement mise en
cause précisément parce qu'elles sont
ressentis parce qu'elles sont visibles
mais il ya aussi des injonctions plus
discrète des injonctions qui s'incarne
dans des croyances
et dans des habitudes
des enfants font des caprices
cadre manche d'un laitage
les gens qui s'aiment vraiment vivre
ensemble dans un ensemble et doivent
constituer une cellule économique
etc on pense que c'est comme ça que ça
doit être parce que ça l'a toujours été
mais ces injonctions nous aliène
lorsqu'elles sont inadaptées à nos
besoins et à nos aspirations
et leur invisibilité nous rend
profondément fataliste
et impuissant
et puis il y a les injonctions qui
prennent la forme de valeurs
le principe
d'idéaux
deux modèles de réussite ou
d'épanouissement
ces injonctions
elle exerce sur nous une contrainte
morale parce que nous les célébrants
nous pensons que nous leur devons notre
valeur
nous pensons qu'elles font de nous des
créatures supérieur
mentir c'est mal
donner sans compter ses biens
une femme s'accomplit en devenant maire
la famille secret
quand nous nous risquons à sortir du
cadre défini par ses injonctions
invisible
nous perdons notre valeur sociale nous
perdons notre dignité notre droit
d'appartenir au groupe nous faisons
partie
nous nous sentons coupables et nous
méritons d'être puni
les valeurs sont assurément les
injonctions les plus toxiques
potentiellement elle nous prescrivent
des désirs qui n'ont pas toujours les
nôtres
et elle nous empêche petit à petit
de savoir
ce que nous voulons vraiment
au point
que nous ne savons plus quoi faire de
notre liberté
si on prend du recul on voit que toutes
ses injonctions
sont des prisons
elle constitue autour de nous des
cellules
qui nous enferment
et nous isole et les deux seuls choix
qui nous ont laissés c'est
de nous en prendre à nos co détenus
en leur attribuant ce sentiment
d'oppression d'étouffement de captivité
qu'on peut ressentir
ou de nous en prendre à nous mêmes
en
renonçant en abdiquant
on ne recherchant plus des relations
authentiques
et forcément on cherchera et
satisfaction de substitution
on regardera la télé actuellement 3h47
par français par jour
on refera de ménage alors que la maison
est propre
on passera des heures sur les réseaux
sociaux
on regardera les saisons d'une série
géniale
et puis on perdra de vue que la vie peut
être magique
on en a qu'une à priori
et que c'est maintenant
des injonctions ou rendent violent
envers les autres
et envers nous mêmes
comme des détenus
alors comment on sort de prison
d'abord on se débarrasse
de cette idée absurde que notre liberté
s'arrête là où commence celle des autres
que l'autre serait une entrave à la
liberté
cette absurde parce que nous sommes des
animaux sociaux
et que le monde serait vide et froid
si notre liberté se résumait
à la possibilité de faire ce que l'on
veut
c'est absurde parce que ce que l'on veut
avant tout
ce n'est pas faire ceci ou cela
c'est être écouté
compris
reconnue
désiré oui mais
et sont des choses qu'on ne peut pas
obtenir si on ne donne pas aux autres ce
qu'ils attendent de nous voilà
notre liberté se joue
dans les liens que nous tissons
et la force
et la beauté de ses liens dépendent très
étroitement de notre capacité à nous
ajuster
les uns aux autres
le souci c'est que parfois on n'arrive
pas à s'ajuster
bien sûr si on n'est pas pas la première
chose à faire c'est de se débarrasser de
ses fonctions
d'écouter ses enfants et s'écouter soi
même
de ses forces et de cultiver une
empathie mutuelle
fluide continue dans un effort
le plus permanent possible d'attention
et d'ajustement
mais l'ajustement n'est pas toujours
possible et parfois ça aide de mobiliser
des règles n'est pas n'importe comment
et pas n'importe lesquels
des règles
qu'on définit
et qu'on est con défini ensemble
alors comment on fait pour définir
ensemble
des règles nous rapproche
depuis près de dix ans
dans le cadre de mon activité
d'ingénieurs sociale
je travaille sur
ces liens qui rapproche
et dans ce cadre j'ai élaboré une
méthode plutôt simple qui permet de
développer l'empathie mutuelle
la première étape de cette méthode
consiste à identifier des aspirations
que les personnes vont pouvoir
satisfaire les unes les autres
l'inspiration les envies et besoins de
toutes les personnes impliquées dans la
situation
la deuxième étape consiste à identifier
les contributions que les personnes vont
pouvoir sa portée les unes aux autres
chacun en fonction de ses envies
et de ses capacités
la troisième étape consiste à comprendre
et à imaginer quel système de règles
permet
d'offrir le plus de satisfaction
possible
à ces aspirations qu'on a identifié
pour le la contribution pour l'effort le
plus modeste qui soit
l'enjeu est de trouver une règle
qui permet d'ajuster l'offre et la
demande
les besoins et les capacités pour qu'un
lien durable et mutuellement que se
tisse où se développent
regardez mon propos je vais en revenir à
mes enfants et je vais vous raconter
comment j'ai essayé de résoudre un
problème qui se pose est quotidiennement
vous l'avez peut-être deviné je ne suis
pas un père naturellement autoritaire
souci quand on ne fait pas du tout peur
à ses enfants
c'est qu'on peut répéter 15 fois la
folie dans range ta chambre
fais tes devoirs
il ne se passe rien
et on n'est pas entendu
et à la fin c'est pénible
alors on s'énerve
on essaie de faire peur un petit peu
mais on se reconnaît plus vraiment
un jour je me suis mis en tête d'
appliquer cette méthode que j'ai
développée dans le cadre de mon travail
à ce souci que j'avais dans la ville
mes enfants
que voulait-il il voulait que je ne
cherche pas à les commander et comme ils
disent
il cherchait à jouer et il cherchait ce
que je leur fasse plaisir que je les
emmène à la piscine au zoo
à l'aquarium
il avait envie
je pense de ce dont tous les enfants
avaient envie
de mon côté j'avais envie qu'il soit
plus autonome
et j'avais aussi envie de passer du bon
temps avec eux
j'ai donc envisager mes enfants comme
des
partenaires
et plus comme des petits soldats
qui devait obtempéré aux injonctions
dont je me faisais le relais
alors je leur ai dit
vous
réalisez spontanément
sans que je vous le demande
toutes ces choses que tôt ou tard vous
finirez bien par faire c'est routine du
quotidien
alors vous disposerez du temps que vous
mourrez épargné
je voulais qu'ils comprennent que plus
vite il réalise les routine du quotidien
plus il nous reste deux temps
pour des choses précieuses et
intéressant
chaque tâche réalisée spontanément leur
faisait gagner un certain nombre de
minutes minutes que je m'étais engagé à
leur restituer encore plus agréable
en fin de semaine
l'effet a été immédiat mes enfants se
sont mis accumulé des centaines de
minutes
jusqu'à m'extorquer
une après midi entière dans un parc
aquatique
la dynamique s'est poursuivie est entré
dans notre quotidien et un jour
j'ai surpris
un ami d'un de mes fils
en train de balayer la cuisine je me
suis dit je tiens quelque chose lui
aussi voulait gagner des minutes
avec mon associé j'ai donné à ce
principe
la forme d'un jeu avec un plateau des
cases des pions des cartes qui
représentait les actions des cartes qui
représentait les bons moments qu'on
allait pouvoir passer ensemble
et puis on l'a testé dans de nombreuses
familles à chaque test on s'ajuste est
un petit peu mieux aux aspirations des
enfants des parents
et le système de règles évoluer
doucement
pour que tout soit le plus harmonieux
possible
que les aspirations et les capacités de
chacun soient prises en compte
et puis on l'a lancé
et désormais chaque semaine nous
recevons des témoignages de parents qui
nous remercient les avoir rapproché
leurs enfants
que ce soit en france en suisse au
canada
qu'est ce qu'on voit si on prend un peu
plus de recul encore
on voit finalement que nous vivons
tout
nos relations
dans des prisons invisible
des prisons invisible dont les portes
sont désormais ouvertes
des prisons que nous quittons pas pour
autant
ces prisons ce sont toutes les
injonctions souvent inconsciente
qu'ils nous disent ce qu'on doit être
on doit penser
on doit croire ce qu'on doit faire
elles ne répondent aux aspirations de
personnes et nous enferme chacun dans
notre cellule
la bonne nouvelle
et qu'il ne tient qu'à nous
de sentir la pression continue de ses
injonctions d'apprendre
à sentir cette pression continue
et cela dans toutes nos relations
familiales professionnelles amicales
amoureuses avec nous mêmes
et une fois ressenti cette pression
apporter ses injonctions
à la lumière
bien souvent
cela suffit à les dissiper
nous pouvons alors inventé
avec les personnes de notre vie
les liens dont nous avons vraiment
envie
car ce n'est pas de problème
le problème ce n'est pas notre métier ce
n'est pas nos enfants y nos collègues ni
nos patrons
le problème c'est pas le casting
c'est le scénario merci